- And you're Joe.
- Goldberg.
(romantic jazz music)
Have you been naughty
or nice, little girl?
When we live together your
place won't be a pigsty.
I'll clean for us.
And you won't eat all this frozen shit,
I'll cook for you everyday, I promise.
I'll even do your laundry.
- [Woman] No, I can't report him.
That's not how it works.
- I'm not worried,
I've seen enough romantic
comedies to know guys
like me are always
getting in jams like this.
Look at that!
How dare she invade
your privacy like that!
It's perverse!
God, I have to pee.
Bec, you've got a stalker.
And that was way too much.
There it is, with its big naked windows.
It's nice, too nice.
I'm thinking subsidized school housing.
Jesus, it's like you've
never seen a horror movie,
or the news.
I'm not bothering you, just checking in.
But then the world
wouldn't know your poetry.
- How do you know I write poetry?
- Doesn't every young writer in New York?
- Should I get the queen
or the king size bed?
- Your bedroom isn't big
enough to fit a king.
- You're right it's too,
how do you know that?
- It's New York, no one's
bedroom is big enough
to fit a king.
- [Man] Hey, let me up.
- Bec, who the fuck is this?
(thud)
(glass breaking)
But as much I'm hoping
this is just a stage,
that quick password search
on your iPad has revealed
a swipe-fest of millennial manboys.
Guy with tiger.
Junior William Morris agent.
Viking wannabe.
You've been a busy girl, Bec.
It's more competition than I realized.
If I want to win your heart,
I'm going to have to show you.
I'm not a maybe, I'm the one.
How do I segueway this
from browsing glassware
to holy shit, Joe's the one.
Oh, there it is.
No matter how hard you
fight me, I will always make
sure you password protect your devices.
You are good, Bec, you're medicine.
You're the antidote for
liars and you make cheating
a distant memory, right
now I love you so much
the ringing in my head is music.
(woman shrieks)
Sometimes we do bad things
for the people we love.
(woman retches)